So how does this compare against the classical pipeline?
Well, the story process is integrated and can be more easily modified throughout the
production allowing directors to leverage a more live-action shot construction process.
Next, Sequencer becomes the production hub and can even act as the editorial system if
desired.
This creates a very director-centric solution where the revision process is more interactive
and the creative team can view final pixels directly in engine and in real time.
To help supplement Unreal's ability to work with other applications, Epic supplies Datasmith,
a series of conversion libraries to help translate and test late incoming CAD and spline-based
data into Unreal.
This is a major benefit for members of the art department who heavily rely on CAD-based
tools to construct concept art and precision models for physical set construction.
These actions are further enhanced by Python to help automate these translations.
This ability to aggregate data from multiple sources allows Unreal the ability to act as
your central hub of production.
If you have a need to work in another application, support is present to allow these applications
to do what they do best and bring that work into Unreal if needed.